Christian's with us in Los Angeles hi
Christian how are you excellent Dave
thank you very much
longtime listener first-time caller just
a quick question
I was recently approached by a solar
company usually I send them quickly away
because I'm not going to lease the
panel's I don't have the money to buy
them outright but there's a program that
they're offering called the power
purchase agreement I don't know if
you're familiar with it it's just
financing with solar panels oh so it's
the same thing even though I'm just
buying the power at they say that they
only go up 2.9 percent annually and SCE
who I currently buy 10% but I didn't
feel comfortable with it because I would
never own the equipment anyway and it
seems like they would pay off the
panel's you know or their cost you know
a lot sooner than the 20-year contract
that I would be in so I was just
wondering if it was not only different
or not no it's not a different the solar
panels are great if you can pay cash for
them and you can run an analysis that
says I get my cash back in five years or
less meaning the cost of the electricity
and the the amount of Sun that you have
in the area are is what that's what
creates the analysis I actually endorse
solar panel companies in several cities
around America with our local radio
stations that I want but I don't endorse
them to be financed in any possible
scenario so write a check and if you
spend $10,000 on them or 12,000 dollars
or whatever it is you got the money
you're just investing in it and then you
know are we gonna save that much in
electricity given our power rate or like
the rate of what we charge for
electricity in our area and given the
amount of sunshine that's going to go
into these panels the good news is man
solar panels courts been around for
decades and the good news is the
technology is in the quality of them and
the efficiency of them the technology is
getting a lot lot better which makes the
breakeven to happen faster you get your
money back faster because they're that
much more efficient than they used to be
they kind of used to be clunky
technology and they're just doing it
a lot better job with them now some
areas of the country with the Sun you
know the amount of days of sunshine that
you get and the ability to store the
power and the some of the processes I've
got with some of the power companies
makes it really really attractive but I
would never do it if I didn't pay cash
reform